what do you think the success of six
month will have on weather girl I think
well I hope it will impact it very
positively I mean I don't know you never
know about that kind of thing but I feel
like even now even now doing promotion
for six month rule I'm talking about my
past work people are looking up weather
girl and saying oh you guys watched the
trailer you know it's like that has
brought that movie to you guys so
hopefully it'll it'll open it up to a
lot more people i'm really proud of that
film and I i love you know when the cast
continues to work and do all these
things and you never know what's gonna
bring people back to weather girl like i
would assume that the success of suits
what has brought a lot of people to see
Patrick jams and weather girl and you
know Mark Harmon show just keeps getting
more popular and you know so they go and
they watch by the girl but I'm hoping
that people like six month rule and want
to see what else I've done and if they
do what the girl should be the number
one rental
you